premier titre à la une de l'actualité
donc aujourd'hui
klaus barbie criminels de guerre ancien
chef de la gestapo lyonnaise a passé sa
première nuit en prison au fort montluc
de lyon à l'endroit même choisi
symboliquement d'ailleurs où pendant
l'occupation il fit emprisonner et tué
des milliers de résistants français dont
leur chef jean moulin et déportés près
de 7500 juifs première pièce de notre
dossier aujourd'hui en compagnie nos
envoyés spéciaux isabelle bechler et
michel halal lalonde a man revivre les
heures qui ont précédé l'arrivée de
klaus barbie à lyon et son entrée au
fort montluc de lyon tout le monde
attendait le dc-8 militaire qui a mené
klaus barbie en france à l'aéroport de
satolas selon le plan de vol initial
toute la presse des curieux bien sûr
mais aussi d'anciens résistants
socialement 74 me tester je vais sauver
personnellement le cosby bien sûr
qu'elle est tombée du projet moi mon
point de vue et prend garde chaude mais
certains surtout qui parle pour dénoncer
ce qu'ils veulent donner la main est-ce
qu'il peut pas avoir fait ses courses
ensemble déportés et que de nombreux
morts il ya des gens de lyon qui lui en
veut normale vers 21h on apprenait que
l'avion s'était finalement posé sur la
base aérienne militaire de corbas dans
la banlieue lyonnaise et on attendait
encore mai au palais de justice cette
fois que klaus barbie soit présentée au
juge d'instruction
mais c'est directement au fort montluc
l'ancienne prison militaire où il avait
lui même interrogé et torturé les
résistants de la région que barbie a été
transporté l'incarcération symbolique
dans la présente ses méfaits ne devrait
pas se prolonger plus de quelques jours
en effet le fort montluc est une prison
ne sont incarcérés que des femmes
objecteur de conscience de toute la
soirée nous n'avons pas aperçu klaus
barbie une seule fois une des cinq
personnes à l'avoir vu avec le concept
politique d'un tueur fou c'est le
bâtonnier qui s'est désigné d'office
pour sa défense en attendant ses avocats
ouest-allemand il est il a fait des
déclarations comme la loi les y autorise
en ce qui concerne la le l'inculpation
et la détention
il conteste le chef d'inculpation en
assam nous ne sommes pas au fond comment
l'avez vous retrouver physiquement comme
un homme qui vient de passer trois jours
dans des avions qui a subi le décalage
horaire et qui a quand même 70 ans